china puts huge resources in money and
personnel behind boosting its strategic
and political influence around the world
this can be seen in china's recent
military exercises around taiwan
but many of its influence operations are
much less dramatic
they're conducted in the shadows
involving subtle and largely secret
moves to expand beijing's strategic
reach with me to discuss this is john
lee a senior fellow at the hudson
institute in the us he's also served as
a senior national security adviser to
the australian government john thanks
for joining us from sydney could you
start by telling us about the role that
the people's liberation army plays and
why it refers to these campaigns as
political warfare the people's
liberation army is not a normal
professional military that you might see
in the united kingdom or united states
or australia the army is loyal to the
chinese communist party and the chinese
communist party sees itself as engaged
in
a political and military warfare with
the west particularly united states now
military warfare hasn't started we
haven't had a war with china for quite a
long time but political warfare is seen
as the same thing but not using military
assets so if you think about warfare
warfare is really about getting your
enemy or your opponent to do something
they wouldn't otherwise do you can do
that through the use of force but the
chinese communist party thinks about
warfare as something that you do whether
it's in peace time or wartime and this
leads to the whole conversation about
influence operations and information
operations
thanks john so that's the background
let's talk if possible about a concrete
case uh earlier this year china signed a
security agreement with the government
of manasse govari the prime minister of
the solomon islands a country which is
not too far from australia's own
northeastern coast
would you say that influence operations
played a role in preparing the ground
for this initiative
china has long wanted a security pact or
military assets in a solomon and in
other parts of the south pacific for
that matter back in 2018 the chinese
were talking about a very similar
security pack with vanuatu and and that
pact was ultimately
scuppered because it was leaked to the
media and there was a bit of a
ground swell in vanuatu against that
kind of agreement with china now china
learnt from that uh what they've done in
the solomons is that they have
done a lot better at elite capture what
authoritarian elites actually want is
remain in power it is not primarily to
necessarily improve the fortunes of the
country so what china has done with the
saga of ira government it has given
resources to help the sake of our
government remain in power if you go to
solomon islands there's a very heavy
chinese presence so for example they'll
spread narratives uh like
that china's domination of the
pacific is inevitable
uh the best thing you can do is
come to a beneficial arrangement with
china now before it's too late you'll
also hear lots of narratives about how
the chinese have never colonized the
pacific or asia for that matter now
these aren't just nice sounding bits of
propaganda they are all designed to
feed into the way strategic elites in
countries including the solomons think
about the chinese presence so you
mentioned there about china providing
resources to the sogovari government and
this chart shows how china's loans and
grants to the south pacific region
including the solomon islands have grown
over the last decade
china's desire for greater influence in
the region fundamentally
links back to the taiwan issue that i
mentioned at the start because china has
a policy of isolating taiwan
diplomatically
in order to encourage or coerce it
into becoming a part of mainland china
the south pacific is a long way away but
it is a part of of the diplomatic chess
game
that this has engendered and the south
pacific it contained some of the last
remaining countries in the region that
officially recognized taiwan
the solomon island switched its
recognition to mainland china in
2019 and beijing has promised it about
730 million
us dollars in financial aid but the
latest deal is called a security pact
and the terms of that deal have been
kept secret
the us
and its ally australia are concerned
that it's the first step towards the
establishment of a chinese military base
in the south pacific and that's
something that china denies
but now the u.s ability to project power
through a network of military bases in
the region considerably exceeds that of
china but washington has said recently
that it would not rule out the use of
force
if china was to set up a military base
in the solomon islands what do you make
of that threat that sort of comment has
to be understood in the context of
a potential war in the western pacific
what the united states is essentially
indicating is that
in the wartime situation it would target
chinese assets no matter where they were
so it's essentially trying to tell these
smaller countries if you don't want to
be caught up in strategic competition
don't allow the chinese to put security
and military assets
on your territory switching to australia
you're very much on the front lines of
this john you've witnessed chinese
influence campaigns in australia i think
um
could you sketch out for us where the
battle lines as it were of these
influence campaigns have been drawn and
what kind of role
does the people's liberation army play
as you explained earlier in this kind of
political warfare
if you think about what china is trying
to do in countries like australia and
indeed in many other
american allied countries in the asian
region is trying to prevent these
countries from speaking out against
chinese values or chinese behavior now
the united front is the main body that
oversees
campaigns in foreign countries
but the people's liberation army to pla
it is one of the main entities within
china there to support united front
there's not much of a
separation
between the united front and the pla in
the sense that the pla does both the
normal military activities you would
expect but also does the influence
activities uh which is guided by the
united front and so what kind of
examples of this kind of influence
campaign can we see in australia the uh
chinese diaspora in australia is a very
big target for the pla and the chinese
communist party
there's around 1.2 million australians
of chinese descent now if you think
about uh why beijing uh is interested in
targeting the australian chinese
diaspora because it's trying to create
this unity within australia it sees the
multicultural nature and open society of
australia as a potential weakness as a
potential avenue of influence
now if you look at the chinese language
media in australia and chinese language
media is very important because most
mainland chinese australians
obviously speak mandarin as the first
language and most of them consume
chinese language media they don't tend
to consume a lot of english language
media yes i've looked into that and
according to a report from aspy the
australian foreign policy think tank
three of the 24 chinese language media
groups in australia are known to get
funding from the chinese communist party
and about half have links to the united
front
has this influenced the way in which
these media groups
cover stories specifically those about
china do they for instance present the
chinese communist party point of view
when it comes to issues that beijing
really cares about
like taiwan their content is derived
from state organizations from within
china
and then if you look at what kind of
content they're they are trying to
spread
the content
it's not just things about
china's preferred position on taiwan or
the south china sea but it is to spread
narratives like
the chinese communist party and the
chinese people are one in the same
you'll hear messages like china's
success is inevitable that the chinese
communist party is undeterrable that the
west is weak then america is divided so
all of those elements
come together to try to weaken the will
of
australia to resist
beijing's policies uh in the region and
within australia and the primary way it
tries to do that is to create this unity
um and indecision uh in in
amongst australian elites and amongst
the australian government so would you
say that these influence campaigns are
effective using australia again as an
example
i mean if you look at the trajectory of
australia's relationship with china over
the past four to five years you'd have
to say
that relations have deteriorated sharply
so in a sense is china actually scoring
an own goal
in these influence campaigns these
influence campaigns are very effective
if the country decides to remain passive
so if you look at australia prior to
around 2016 i would say that
china was was very effective
the way we talked and the way we thought
was actually quite conducive to what the
chinese communist party wanted
now what changed um the
australian government
decided to publicize a lot of these
activities the point i'm making is that
we do have uh defenses against these
sorts of influence campaigns but if you
remain passive they can become quite
corrosive
they can cause a country to self-censor
they can cause a country to become
more indecisive about
taking on some of the more
forward-leaning policies of china
so it does require an act of will and a
preparedness to absorb cost inflicted by
china i look at some other countries
around around our region new zealand
will be one many countries in southeast
asia would be another i think that the
influence campaigns have taken quite
deep root and will take quite a bit of
political willpower uh to challenge and
change things around so finally john
would you say that australia being in
the asia pacific region has
made it an early example of how
a chinese influence campaign could look
when china really decides to turn up the
pressure
and and if so
does the australian example have
relevance for other countries around the
world
australia is certainly a very good
example for
an american ally
which is also an open multicultural
society when you look at more homogenous
societies you know for example japan
taiwan
uh i i think it's harder for china to
pursue those sorts of divisive tactics
uh simply because
uh it's it's harder to divide society
according to either ethnic lines or or
other lines in in in those sorts of
cultures thank you very much for joining
us john my pleasure thank you for having
me